ladies and gentlemen lying talks and now
something to blue determine a man with a
two recorder on his nose so lanik talks
place down tidy up the road off who here
doesn't know the rules about lining
talks who okay simple it's five minutes
of talk no questions so I will control
time that will be a tight control on
time and it's five minutes when there's
one minute left I will clap once okay
like this easy peasy and then when it's
five minutes I'll would start clapping
okay and all of you will clap with me
okay like it I don't know variety show
something like that to Lex practice
right don't disappoint me
okay ready set go ok hello everyone my
name is Gabriella math too and I want to
make you a really fast question how many
of you here do you usually use a few
bitter in your daily basis and that
please ok lot of you so I'm quite sure
that you are quite bored of having the
same experience and everybody has to
experience the same font and the same
colors for the text editor so I just
wanted to explore this a little bit more
and I just found that they use code
mirror that it's another problem it has
javascript poop plugin and it's a
plug-in that they use in the Jupiter and
notebooks just to show the code and make
some syntax color on it so I started
looking to the API of coding me of
Chimaera and I found out that they have
a lot of themes for the code for the
color of the of the code so you can
modify it as you want so I try to hug it
a little bit i made a very little
JavaScript script and what it this I
script lets you is just modify this
syntax so what this makes you is to have
another color in your syntax oh it's
super simple but you can use and
personalize your own Jupiter to see the
code in another color so to make it as
easy as possible I just introduced
everything in the sell options and you
can modify the font if you want or
modify the color so you can put like the
normal color of it you can put I don't
know maybe some extreme color and if you
want to change also the font now just go
and there is like a variety of phones
that you can choose from so the idea of
this was not to hug and create like
something that goes over it but use the
API that it's below and try to make it
like in a cleaner way so if you want to
install it it's super simple just you
have to go to the Jupiter themes
repository it's mercurial it's on github
mercurial Jupiter themes and then you
just put that on your bash control and
you will get it right now there is no
window support if any windows user wants
to trade please just open an issue and
help us to give some support to the
Windows user too that's it thank
thanks for the lining lining talk
I don't want to get you nervous but
expectation is high guarantee come on
line three two this is going to be very
fun yeah set yes so three two one go
okay I have a special place in hell
reserved for those that repealed talks
from time to time but not for me because
this is like the fourth or fifth or
sixth time that I better get this talk
but I'm trying to introduce a couple of
changes first of all I'm going to do it
it life so I don't have any result in
the code right now and I change the
trajectory so it's going to be a little
bit different the jokes are going to be
the same so please bear with me okay so
this is a total too much with Python
using polyester in five minutes so we've
been talking about you know there are
were a couple of speakers saying like
you know this is not rocket science this
is not difficult what this is rocket
science okay what is astrodynamics in
the first place where astronomic sees
branch of mechanics which is itself a
branch of physics which is that is the
motion of interplanetary probes in space
for instance i have here the plot of the
rosetta mission which is a european
mission that went to a comet with your
money and as you can see there the
tragedy was pretty involved because it
was going through the earth first then
was passing through Mars than the earth
again then one asteroid then another
asteroid then another flyby to the earth
and then after 10 years either right to
the comet so you can imagine already
that this problem is pretty complex in
what is polyester it's a python library
the developing for studying discount
programs so let's go to Mars I changed
the problem as I told you for the talk
so I'm going to study the trajectory or
of the exomars mission that was launched
like one month ago and it's a joint
mission with your man
and Russia's money so here is the
impulse that I needed first so here we
import map lovely and very basic things
about units time and stuff like that and
now I import everything related to
polyester including some fight from NASA
which will tell me where are the planets
exactly first I have to define the orbit
so I just need the position and velocity
of the planet will respect to some
attractor in this case and just plotting
a spacecraft around the earth so I need
the position the velocity and specifying
the release yes so here it is the next I
have to locate the planets so here i
specify a specific time and using the
NASA files that i told you about before
I'm able to locate the position and
velocity of these planets respect to the
Sun third I have to compute the
trajectory this is called like a
boundary problem in this domain and in
this case the name is the Lambert
problem so I implemented a faction to to
solve it through a new algorithm and
hear what I get is what is the
trajectory that I have from one planet
to the other the real thing is that this
is pure python even if it's a very
complex mathematical algorithm because I
managed to accelerate the whole thing
with numba and so I managed to throw
away like 10,000 lights of fortune and
now listing incense on windows so let's
go to Mars already I have to execute
this function over here and I have this
little function here which is go to Mars
and now you can see okay that i have--
this trajectory which is exactly the
tree from the earth 14th match when in
the future when it arrives the 19th of
october and actually you can see here
that the tray 3 is pretty strange
because it's outside of the plane and
now let's make it interactive i don't
know if you've ever seen the ipython
widgets but if you haven't then today
it's a good opportunity ok here i have
the
same problem but I have two variables
which are which are the offset in the
launch time and also a variable which
controls the flight the time of light
which controls how fast or how slow I go
to the planet so if I move here the
offset you will see that the earth goes
forward in the orbit okay and also Mars
and all the planets and everything and
if i put a time-of-flight a bit smaller
i get a shorter and shorter orbit until
i have to reach the speed of light which
of course doesn't work and that's all
okay three two one go well this is I'm
going to hell because what are delivered
but I did this in Barcelona at what 30
minutes so here I'm going to do in five
minutes is going to just going to be a
quite different dog it's going to be out
its circular and pandas one of the
problems with succulent and partners why
the wasn't doesn't go though oh is that
the cycle air was created before pandas
was born so cyclone only its new Pia
raised to work with while pandas what
you got numpy arrays but you get a lot
of different nitrogenous types of
columns so you have to convert this this
pandas dataframe to a numerical right to
fit it to the secular models okay and
this is not important so it's the
problem work you cannot use it directly
and this is bad so well what we need to
be pre-processing so you can you can do
different kinds of pre-processing with
numerical variables with categorical
variables or yeah and you can use
different secular provides you different
transformers to transform these this
original varias into something you can
fit to the to the secular models but
when you have a terror genius data is
not so easy to deal with all the barrio
see here we have an example with the
Titanic data set which is from Cagle
where you want to transform some of the
value of some of the are categorical
American then what here you can see the
kind of parable that you have you want
to predict if people died or surviving
in the Titanic accident okay then you
want to do certain pre-processing and
you need kind cut
long chunk of code to do this and this
is not something the 0 i think in art
you can just put a formula and get
everything more or less well not all the
purpose in I do here you can do it fast
but in a more pythonic way i will say
that in here in this python then when
the transfer me to do the prediction
then what the issues that is that you
have to write out of code to manual code
to do the pre-processing inside to read
and also you cannot integrate it right
with pipelines so one of the packets I
use every day my my job is secular and
punish the kind of bridge to convert
this dis- data frames two to two pi to
non p arrays to fit to their models well
it was created by a guy from Cagle and
maintain it with people from google and
no I'm maintaining it so it's good and
then it's the same tactics but like it
is is I think is more or less intact
sugar because in the end you are
applying the same code they're the
things that are working the same but i
think the sin that is much more you see
it's easier to read so it's you define
instead of having to do right all they
got you just define the column do you
want to transform under transformers you
want to apply to them okay more or less
like that and then it was you can put
this into a pipeline so you can put the
frame mapper what is called before and
then the classifier and everything works
well and you can use it also this inside
the inside a cross validation or also
with a grid search okay and the fire was
is that well in my opinion i think that
the circular transformers they are not
they still thought to work with
numerical race and not with for example
like string-based variables where you
have categories and some other things
that are not very easy to use then i
think they have to improve and also i
learned that for some tools i started
using this and i think that and then I
become devonte know what I think is
for many packages even you think that
people that work on free software are
superheroes you can also going to do
this to free software and it's not so
hot but I promise that if you are
maintaining a package for that a lot of
people uses you have to be careful of
course with great power comes great
responsibility and one of the some of
the things i want to do with with these
secular pandas packets is to do like
paralyzed transformation because
nowadays they are doing a serial fashion
while the rest of them is not so
important so I think that's all
okay that's how it's going to work
that's what is okay so ready yeah cept
so my likes how many bike-sharing users
are out here in this room okay I feel so
at least you know what it is a six years
ago I wanted to use the local bike
sharing system Barcelona and realized
that their website was a pain to use and
somehow I wanted to access it better so
I learned the wonders of scraping as a
whole so I released open missing which
was an Android tablet was for accessing
by trying information in Barcelona I did
the same in Paris then in London and
blah blah then I did something called
city bikes which is the same project but
aggregating information for the whole
world so basically what started just
here ended up as a library that supports
more than 400 different cities in all
the world and we can see that if i get a
browser oh yeah here so this is a visa
map of the current coverage and i don't
know if you can see but all these places
are real time usage of bike sharing in
different cities for instance i can look
for barcelona and we can see some people
using their so somebody left a bicycle
there that's somebody taking a bicycle
and so on and by now you might wonder
why madrid it's not here and madrid it's
not here basically because they they
don't have this data set open and their
website has an image instead of an
interactive map basically because they
want to avoid being scraped what another
thing we can see since this presentation
started roughly 300 400 bicycles have
been taken and for her
having left and so 5x which was actually
what I wanted to to tell you about how
is it is to use this library it this is
not using any kind of API I mean we have
an API on the project that you can use
but of course you'll have the Python
library where you can add your own city
so basically this is a program that will
give you the stations that are around
you if you pass and others like I don't
know we can look for any address here
and it will give you the five nearest
stations that are around you and all
these not using the API by choosing this
Python library so if you are interested
just please go to the repository at your
own City fix bugs whatever and because I
have some more time looks like by now
you are wondering by worried that much
about bicycles I mean it's can get a
pretty boring but I discovered this it
is called public-private partnerships
which is what happens when you let
private companies from public projects
which is they kidnap this public
information and make it their own so the
city consulates forced to pay to these
companies to make them an Android app
using their information so what we want
to say on all these open that the smart
city kool aid stuff it's if you want
open data just open it go for it instead
of just creating hackathons and
conversation stuff and if you wonder
about the android app i started we are
not working on that anymore because we
realized that doing the open api or 5x
was very important than just doing an
android app because information its way
superior to just representations because
representations are just a poor
interpretation of data and while this is
the end yeah
Shango voice arpu her poem porque si
antigua lo siento so attention ready set
go okay so I'm going to try to explain
very quickly what it's a genetic
algorithm genetic algorithms are based
on the natural evolution which a process
that optimize living things during time
through natural selection like killing
the left feet animals or whatever and
reproducing are the most feet creatures
with genetic algorithms we will try to
do something like that but with
solutions to a problem for example I
want to optimize the problem of an
artful which is like flying in the wind
and I want to optimize where for example
the aerodynamic drag or anything so our
population will be made of individuals
which have to be described by a series
of parameters which must be the same
parameter for every individual because
we have to compare each individual with
the others so for example we can
describe an airfoil with a series of
points which are then joined with for
example a vessel cool or whatever so
this is an example of how can we
describe under full so we can generate a
certain air flow with this kind of
curves and we only need like 16
parameters which are numbers so these
numbers can be code in binary
making like a DNA but instead of being
made of chemicals are made of bits so
the first step we will have to
transcript the genetic code into the
values of these traits then the trades
which are for example the geometrical
points of the of the airfoil have to be
executed have to be analyzed in order to
get like the performances this is the
step which is the typical problem we
want to optimize in this case we will
have an aerodynamic program which will
analyze the ire fall and get the
aerodynamic forces or whatever and then
the last step is get a final final
fitness function which will compress
everything every performance into a
single number okay the fitness function
is the most important function in the
whole algorithm and is where you have to
focus in order to get a proper working
algorithm so every loop is called a
generation because it's like a
generation or animals or or person or
whatever and we start with a population
then we analyze the population we select
and kill people and then we reproduce
the survivors in order to get a new
population okay the selection can be a
selecting the most fit it can be random
and okay we have to make an equilibrium
between how many people we kill and how
many people survive in order to not lose
a lot of information but at the same
time get room for new people and
reproduction we'll get a new population
from the survivors we can as well depend
the revolution on the fitness or make it
random if you make random the both
processes we will not get evolution we
have to make at least one of the two
depending on the fitness fitness of the
population there are two steps in
reproduction first with cross we will
mix the DNA of two parents in order to
get a child and then the mutation will
change small bits
of the child in order to get new
individuals which are not exactly like
their parents so we will explore new
areas of the solution space of our
problem for opening the algorithm
typically we can generate random strings
of ones and zeros in order to get our
genomes and for stopping criteria we can
use a fixed number of generations or
just check if our solution is stable
with Python we can do it easily just by
hand you seen objects but we also have a
very nice library called da de AP which
will happen to appear if you google
genetic algorithm Python so that's all I
hope you at least get some interest in
this kind of algorithm because they are
very fun to use
ready okay ready set go hello my name is
javier martin and i work at cat ODB I'm
the metra sky so this took confront from
a colleague from the sales team that
came the other day to me and said said
to me height we need to know what our
customers are located okay great with
maps let's drum up no no but we do we
need to have a dashboard not a map we
need to have this this map update it as
there I said that is updated this is a
little more complicated but after doing
I realized that is not so complicated if
that is really really see is not rocking
site at all so the challenge here is can
I do it in five minutes so let's strike
and this is the scenario we have a I
initial file with all custom our
customer information it's this file is
in Indian drive and it's come from
another an external application its role
of this file has meta data forest for
the customers and also the payment he
has done in the in the previous month
okay what we are going to do is we are
going to take this this file from the
drive we are going to turn rich this
file with new attribute we want for
example to know what is the V favor of
day of the customer in the in the last
month's it is a new customer if he has
Chinese he has cancelled his
subscription and other another things in
this simplest in this demo we are going
only to calculate ease we are going to i
upload this file to Google Drive and
where we are going to to create we are
going to import this file into car to DB
where we will have another table with
the addresses of our customer this
something that is more or less stable
and updated with new customer but it
hasn't changed and this I address it is
disabled has the the position of the
customers we are gone and we are joined
to both tables and we're show them up
that's all so let's do it you can find
all the code in English up with your
interested in to replicated so we are
ranked all the cells to gain some time
here we have a simple class to upload to
download and to update an existing file
indeed right so here we are the leading
the file and we are creating a data
frame in pandas with it it looked like
something like like this we have an
account ID for its customer the name
mail where he created the account the
current plant and the payments in the
prior prior mods here we are cleaning
this this data set we are removing not
useful columns and we are taking care of
no available values here we enrich the
data frame is really easy with the
applied method so we had identifying the
behavior of each of its customers each
in each rope and we are calculating the
difference between the prior amount and
the current model ok this is the
resulting oh no time ok we are going to
import the file we are going to
synchronize this this file
ok
so the tricky part is we are going to
use a view not a table here our
customers and we are we want to show
them by behavior so new ones are a green
under the one who has cancelled the
subscription are in light blue and we
also want to get some information from
them so we can serve this this map just
published with the subject we can
certainly or just get this iframe an
embedded in the
ready said nope okay that this is the
second time i am in a PI data and I feel
that it should be a bucket talk I think
it's a pretty cool library I I really
love it and it was in wonder so I just
decided to take my charts on my plot
from the previous talk put them together
and pretend this is a proper lightning
talk about bouquet let's see what what
we can do first I'll I'll just get some
data there is nothing tricky if you
don't know just when to question before
you before I I estar how many people
know smoking is it most of you how many
people is is using mostly vodka instead
of my trolley or okay so no so many
people excited as me let's see let's see
why okay so well the first thing if you
used it in notebook project you already
know you need to to run some comment to
make them show on on the notebook then
you usually import it then creating a
figure is as as easy as as this is and
then what really i mean i-i it's been
some comments already regarding pocket
and how these architectural and having
the JavaScript that is all done and we
just take care of sending the right
Jason from from python that it's
basically how it works oh how cool this
is I I totally agree but it's not really
what it excites me I mean I haven't had
the opportunity to build like a fancy
dashboard with pocket that gets updated
with WebSockets all all that what i
really like it's a somehow mind blowing
at the beginning but instead the first
time i was using it i was really
disappointed was like i went to just
write a bar plot y is not about what in
boca is like I what what kind of clothes
are they are they thinking on so it was
really disappointing I don't know if
this is the reason so few people really
really use it here
after using it a couple of times even a
second try I found that just being able
to draw is like it's not a floating
library it just like like my belief that
you can create a bar plot a histogram or
whatever it just like you just draw
things iphone it's so amazing so at here
I I just want to draw circles this is a
scatterplot Bogut doesn't know anything
about the scatterplot so I just take my
data and I say okay this is like the day
Dex the why and the color I want so I
basically get these this plot it's like
half of the data off of an example I I
used before then I can add the the other
half of it the other the other class
they are here then I want to use a
histogram bouquet as I said doesn't know
anything about historians or any kind of
charge so I do it with non-pom fibroids
are quite easy way I get the histogram
that it's basically they the size of the
histogram in that adds up to one for all
the possible beans and the edges like
the they were where they are placed so I
just had this information from numpy and
again as i am just plotting i'll be
plotting just the squares this time
instead of circles baka still doesn't
know anything and i think i'm not sure
i'm not a big expert of my poorly but i
think it's not that easy just to start
mixing a scatter plot with weave bar
charts in in my trolley tour with
histograms in boca as you've seen is
like he's perfectly happy with that so
let's go a little bit more to the extent
that this doesn't make that much sense
but i want to approach some lines
basically i'm plotting the the lines of
the average distant row 44 egh don't try
to find a meaning on that it's lying I
just wanted to draw more esteban on this
plot looks pretty cool and actually I
was guessing when I wrote here purple if
it was really gonna be a color purple it
was so it was like kind of surprising
it's also something pretty cool I just
discover you can also have images on
that so you can just hit a
cut that is amazed as me I would poke it
no and well I think I'll just escape I
won't have time and I wanted to explain
the whole I made they they charge for
the 40 cards I'll just disturb but I
won't have time to finish I just want to
show you these it's not that related to
Boca but second learn just provides
erase different hours for the parameters
of the card for each node so it has one
or a four day for the feet or it
represent when I write for the threshold
when I ready to define the child and
everything and what just something that
makes me really fill in love with Python
like this thing over here just put all
them together it creates a named apple
kind of an object its each over them
it's using like stammers I I don't know
I at the ni I just have independent our
eyes off of that and at the end what I
you cannot show you what i get is just a
list off of nodes where it's noticed our
inimitable so I can just write things it
should be here and I'm done with it it's
like you can never mind hi well you know
what animal topic you can just access
that so it's it's really convenient is
like and really love ho Python just let
you put for our arrays together in a
list of nodes with a really fancy
interfaces as getting the the attributes
so without further ado see you tomorrow